on the afternoon of April 12 1945
the lowering of the White House flag
confirmed the passing of America's 31st
President and from Warm Springs Georgia
the mortal remains of Franklin Delano
Roosevelt began the long trip home
slowly the long black funeral train rolled up
from the south then down Pennsylvania Avenue
to the beat of muffled drums the president was
born for the last time to the executive mansion
that for 12 years had been his official
home the passing of FDR from the American
scene came as a personal shock to the nation
people wept openly unashamed of their grief
run by six white horses the flag-draped
caisson was brought to the main entrance
of the white house carried into the Great
East Room where 80 years before almost to
the day the body of Abraham Lincoln also had
laid in state at Hyde Park his ancestral home
in Dutchess County New York the guns of West
Point cadets rang down the final curtain on
the man of Destiny known round the world as
FDR to measure something of his greatness we
turn back the clock to Franklin Roosevelt
as a young man making his first political
campaign for the time when only 28 years of
age he was elected New York state senator
and brought the powerful Republican machine
that has ruled Dutchess County for 28 years
emerging is a national figure he served President
Wilson this assistant secretary of Navy in 1920 is
running mate of Ohio's James M Cox FDR at the
age of 38 was the youngest vice presidential
candidate in history married on st. Patrick's
Day nineteen five to Anna Eleanor Roosevelt niece
of the illustrious Teddy FDR founded a dynasty
typical of his Hudson River Dutch forebears it was
to the Roosevelt retreat the vacation cottage on
Campobello Island but FDR sailed with his friends
and family after the strenuous campaign for the
vice presidency and it was in these same waters
polio German that was to paralyze his legs but
never his life called in 1928 to the State Capitol
in Albany Franklin Roosevelt was elected governor
of New York with Al Smith his old friend the happy
warrior at his side he threw himself into the
fight for better government became the champion
of the common man was widely talked darvis
next Democratic candidate for the presidency
of the United States and with big genial James
a Farley swinging the gavel the die was cast a
country still mired in the morass of depression
wanted a new president call to Chicago to accept
the nomination governor Roosevelt flew from
Albany with his wife son Elliot and son John
you knew it then but this was the beginning
of an era unparalleled in American history
hezb-e arse appearance in Chicago Stadium with
the beginning of a series of spectacular personal
triumphs swept into office by the greatest
landslide in history his first words were fearless
prophetic I am prepared under my constitutional
duty to recommend the measures that are stricken
nation in the midst of a stricken world may
require these measures or such other measures
as the Congress may build out of its experience
and wisdom I shall speak within my constitutional
authority to bring to a speedy adoption but in the
events that the Congress shall fail to take one of
these two causes in the events that the national
emergency is still critical I shall not evade the
clear course of duty that will then confront me
I shall ask but Congress for the one remaining
instrument to meet the crisis broad executive
power to wage a war against the emergency as
great as the power that would be given to
me if we were in fact invaded by farm fall
FDR's first term was marked by an ominous
period of world unrest men of many nations
were again taking up arms our own national
defense was at its lowest ebb American knew
flood and famine drought from the Dust Bowl
FDR brought farm relief and flood control
water power and giant Public Works
Social Security was born old age insurance
became a new responsibility of government
the price of gold was fixed the American
dollar became the soundest in the world
the forgotten man was remembered
the country held its leader as
a pathfinder the initials FDR began to
stand for progress on national security
the fireside chat became an American institution
with Steve early Marvin McIntyre the White House
secretarial staff helped in the preparation of
his radio reports to the nation the president's
talks were masterpieces of simplicity and
directness my friends the American public
and with that now familiar salutation he brought
his messages straight to the fire sides of the
people he talked with them in their homes about
the vital issues of the day Roswell's never gave
up hope in his battle against infantile
paralysis in the healing waters of Warm
Springs in the White House pool swimming
was his one relaxation his only exercise
are we organized the great Warm Springs
foundation for the eventual benefit of
the nation's half-million polio victims
will forever stand as a living monument
to his name and each year on his birthday all
over the land little children sing his praise
this intimate study of the president and his
beloved Paulo is one of the rare personal
portraits in a busy crowded life for no
man in our time nor in any time perhaps
has been called on to make the momentous
decisions that have been his his one goal
his greatest ambition was to leave the
nations of the world into a lasting peace
loyalty from many nations the king and
queen of England have been guests in this
home with the world's most powerful rulers he
commanded supreme respect with a keen grasp of
international affairs he foresaw by many years
the trend of the world's March 1936 speaking at
Chautauqua New York he gave the nation words
that have been quoted again and again I've
always thought the peace like charity begins
at home and that's why we have the gun at home
here in law and South and Central America
but peace in the Western world is not all
we seek I have seen war I have seen war on
land and sea I have seen blood running from
the wounded I have seen children starving I have
seen the agony of mothers and wives hey hey whoa
19:40 found the nation facing war voters
took the third term issue squarely to the
polls with the magic power of FDR shatter all
president the voice of the people was heard the
results are now conclusive Roosevelt wins the
nation was jubilant FDR had done it again and
at Hyde Park Square Roosevelt and his family
received the well wishes of their neighbors
again the president addressed the nation in
the presence of cabinet members of diplomats
and leaders from nations south of the border
FDR asked for broader powers than had ever
before been given to any American president
the first and fundamental fact is that what
started as a European war has developed as
the Nazis always intended it should develop
into a war for world domination therefore with
profound consciousness of my responsibilities
to my countrymen and to my country's cause
I have tonight issued a proclamation that an
unlimited national emergency exists and requires
the strengthening of our defence to the extreme
limit of our national power and authority
with the world facing the greatest conflict
of all time with the rights of all free people
endangered Roosevelt met Winston Churchill on
the high seas gave a pledge to the world waives
the right of all people to choose their own form
of government history records this dramatic
meeting as the birth of the Atlantic Charter
December 7th 1941 a day of infamy that was
burned into the pages of American history
the president faced a nation United I asked that
the Congress declare that since the unprovoked
and dastardly attack by Japan on Sunday December
7th 1941 a state of war has existed between the
United States and the Japanese Empire in 1942
FDR startled the world by meeting Churchill de
Gaulle in Jareau in Casablanca gave the axis
two words unconditional surrender at Quebec
Roosevelt with Churchill planned the invasion
of Europe and with the future of civilization
in the balance the Roby's too played in this
most critical period is indelibly written in
history at cairo for conferences with Jung Kai
shek FDR wrote a new chapter in international
relations gave assurance to the people of China
of unstinted allied aid in their war against
Japan was the guiding hand in bringing together
the many conflicting forces of east and west
such was the man who met Stalin for the
first time at Tehran who gave the world
its first promise of complete accord between
the three great powers but these were called
the big three was no empty phrase and Franklin
Roosevelt's steadfast in his convictions was
the biggest of them all steaming into Pearl
Harbor for the first time since the outbreak
of war the commander-in-chief conferred with
Admiral Nimitz and General MacArthur that he
took an active part in planning the war
in the Pacific is now apparent for it is
known that from this conference emerged the
blueprint for liberation of the Philippines
FBR began his fourth term in office firm in
his belief that men are capable of their own
government but no king no tyrant no dictator
can govern them as wisely as they can govern
themselves and upon that note he placed the
world's future on the conference table at
the altar made plans to bring together the
nations and the peoples of the world in a
just and lasting peace this fray has recorded
that first step as the San Francisco conference
in this his last report to Congress and
the American people is to be found the
text of his life in the last words of a
man grown tired in public service is a
heritage for all men everywhere accept
the results of this conference at the
beginning our feminine structure
of peace from which we can begin
to build under God that better world in
which our children and grandchildren your
when mine the children and grandchildren
of the whole world must live and can live